hi everybody it's me markiplier you can
believe me I ain't fake it's the real
deal 100% authentic mark EMU straight
from the source the source being my
mom's veggetti way uh it's it's me you
you know it's me oh
because I'm a goddamn mess I'm a klutz
and I have no goddamn idea what I'm
doing so yes I shaved why I'm gonna get
to that but first I'm gonna cry
so why why why why why oh god why Oh
Lord why
oh I cry to the heavens why you guys are
saying I'm not saying that it's just
like it shaved my beard what deal is it
to me but you guys out there who are
currently burning your effigies of me
made out of gum in your closet wait hold
that torch don't do it yet please for
the love of God I need the subs there is
a reason why I shaved and it'll make
sense because of the game that I'm
playing and I'm playing a game look at
me I am playing PewDiePie's tuber
simulator and oh there goes sponsor
eagle come back come back sponsor eagle
please okay anyway so you probably know
about the game already I've actually
been playing since a game first came out
but it was a little buggy the server
stuff wasn't working right away so I was
playing it and it's now to a point where
the game is actually fully working not
fully working because there's these
three sections over here that I don't
know what they're doing and why is there
a heart in a box is that when you
yourself out to youtube and do anything
and everything for subs which is exactly
what I'll do I'll do absolutely anything
for more subscribers holy shet literally
I will do anything anything for more
subscribers like Jesus so anyway this
game your ass bones oh here you go I got
you you so in case you guys don't
know the basic premise of the game uh
the whole design is to funnel as much
money towards Felix as possible which
I'm willing to do because I'm gonna
watch this ad ah okay cool
anyway so now that we got that out of
the way that increased our reward
and the rewards are becoming the world's
greatest tuber which is what I am maybe
I don't know and oh here's the reason oh
god you are you you were mid burn of the
effigy and I completely got sidetracked
as to why I shaved my beard
okay here's why you ready sit down
unless you're already sitting down then
stand up and if you're doing one either
then lie down horizontally this is a
really stupid reason but I'm playing
tuber simulator and it's kind of like
I'm doing the whole adventure over again
so I wanted to shave my beard because
back when I had 99 thousand subscribers
I didn't have a beard I who stitched a
young three pubescent 22 year old who is
desperately making videos in my mom's
basement and that's a fact so I wanted
to give back to my roots so ergo babe
applier that's not what a babe that's
man baby baby plier is here to entertain
you and horrify you with my face so now
that I got that out of the way let's get
to the game uh basically this is me I am
authorized on this if you see this is my
actual account I almost have a million
followers on here which isn't nearly
enough so if you guys wanna you know
maybe actually follow someone and play
this game you might want to follow the
guy with the moustache here and while
you're at it make all of your friends
subscribe - markiplier on youtube I
don't know why they wouldn't be already
like it should be out there every day
knocking on doors to make sure they see
my videos and send me gifts because
that's one of the things that's working
now that wasn't working before I'm gonna
send my one friend a gift and then
receive 1 million four hundred and
thirty two thousand seven hundred and
seventy four gifts thanks guys what boom
Wow oh my god I just reached a hundred
thousand subscribers go
you go ah okay anyway okay so that's
what makes this interesting is because
of the social aspect of it you get to
give and receive gifts but now that the
server's are actually working it's
almost broken for someone with a lot of
followers because I can immediately go
back sponsor you go because you can
immediately go back in receive 415 gifts
and then it's exactly the same amount of
gift egde from four hundred and fifteen
versus 1 million four hundred thousand
so you can see how it's a little broken
for me but I'm okay I'm okay with this
because this is totally fine in my mind
seventy-nine gifts sure what the heck I
get to go back repeatedly do that over
and over again I only have to wait like
ten seconds in between so if you want
that to happen in your game a lot of
followers
put your tuber channel in the comments
and everybody get a big follow chain
going on smart to me yeah let's watch
another ad ah oh man that's awesome
the other half of the game is improving
your tuber rummage and as you can see
I've almost completely filled my room
because that's the status of what makes
a good youtuber it's how cluttered your
room is with random garbage so I've kind
of specialized in comedy and science
which is like my ideal and if I actually
had Talent I'd do that but I don't so I
won't talk to write about it also you
level up right now I'm level Kwanza yeah
right now I'm level 16 and I have two
hundred and forty-two bucks and I
haven't bought a single one they've all
been from gifts from my awesome
followers thanks guys up more alright
then Oh more gifts oh you guys too kind
well time to go chicka what's that oh my
gosh oh you guys are so sweet
oh thank you so much I love you guys Oh
the Bears Oh would you hack Oh
for me huh thank you
these fake digital numbers are
definitely a replacement for happiness
bother you God the other part of the
game is decorating your room and then
the other lesser part of the game is
actually making videos which is
something that honestly I don't even
think you need to do at this point if
you're in my shoes you could just farm
subs from your followers gifts it's
amazing but anyway if you don't want to
do that you can do other stuff like oh
we can watch another ad yes build great
a nice song car oh dude oh god
anyway so you do that to get boosts I
mean why the you prostrate oh oh
god yeah cuz why would you not kidding
though I already made those videos and I
just collected the sweet subscribers out
of them the delicious delectables
subscribers and then you make more
videos but now that I got the boosts
from selling my soul and watching some
ads I get to make none of these our
comedy science
I guess bleach cures acne okay so if you
didn't know Bucs are like the currency
that you actually pay money for the
views and the subs are the things that
you get in the game but awesome on
serega also in the gifts that you get
it's not a direct correlation of the
number but if the gifts you get from
your followers you'll also get gifts as
items in the game which are things that
you put in your studio to make sure that
you are better at whatever the hell you
specialize in doing so I've got a lot of
gifts some of them are low-level fine
and this is how you level up like you
get fan gifts you get gifts from your
fans and you will level up throughout
the game you'll which is like
automatically level up just from getting
these gift from people and I get so many
gifts like my god and then you get
knowledge from that but you don't get
subscribers from the gifts or leveling
up but you do get them from the gifts
from your fans
so right now it's just kind of a bonanza
like a non-stop opening of gifts it's
like a never-ending cycle of gift-giving
and that's kind of why I'm glad that
even though I have a million and 400,000
gifts waiting for me I don't have to
open a million four hundred thousand
gifts and wait for them to get through
it kind of just caps it off him sponsor
Eagle no sponsor eagle oh god where is
he hey
huh got you more now we're getting into
the high-level gift so these are the
things that are gonna kick me up a few
notches
I am so anyway this is game like oh I'll
get back to the actual game very soon
here but I just got to get through yes
because I can't just leave him here that
bother the out of me okay so as you
get levels you get knowledge and
knowledge is what really empowers you as
a creator and allows you to make
everything that you absolutely need to
make throughout your tuber career I know
this everyone knows this you ask anybody
that has ever watched my videos they'll
tell you I got smarter as the years go
on bones oh my god so here's the meat of
the matter the customization and that's
what everybody cares about so if you go
into these things you can actually go to
the store here unlock all the
that you just unlocked from leveling up
and get sweet views and subs out of just
pressing a bunch of buttons talk about
instant gratification it's gone sorry
god yeah my objective is to make my
place look like the biggest
that ever was but kind of keep an area
clear so that the webcam from behind it
looks like my place is clean let's see
here
you mean yeah that's me yeah that looks
like me I'm pretty sure that looks like
me in like 40 years or something like
that many ways sponsor you God once you
do that and you've unlocked everything
that you need to unlock which took a
long time because my god everything
moves so fast in this game for me but
you can actually buy things which is
great it's what everyone wants to do Oh
a bucket to piss in oh hell yeah
see I just try to find the places where
I can absolutely squeeze just absolutely
everything in here so point or how about
how about a nice drink teeny to
commemorate the the the olden days of
drunk minecraft that'd be nice
Oh a spider Oh perfect well we're can I
squeeze you ah
right ready and waiting for that cat to
wake up just lurking behind the turd
lies a dark secret better sleep with one
eye open little puss alright so in the
meantime you can either play puggle
which I'll show you is giant bag of
dicks because hey you might as well just
randomly blindly assemble it wherever
the hell it wants to go because like
it's not gonna love you hey you time
reduction for playing puggle on your
shipments which take right now they take
up to a day nice nice not nice not no
stupid all right I'm gonna extract my
non-existent beard and then hope for the
best
nope there's not nope yeah straight down
the right side it was practically
rocketing into death ah hell yeah ten
percent reduction now there we go
chica wouldn't do this to me chica
wouldn't screw me over like this also
chica would probably get stuck in there
cuz she's much bigger and she probably
just end up all over the place
maxi was funny now that III forgot to
mention uh when I shaved I went to say
hi to chica and she was just a little
scared of me cuz she didn't recognize uh
haha at first at first when she got
close she was like oh it's you but at
first he was like well the hell happened
do you so now that these are done happen
up in 5m yeah I got a bug in a piss hey
mom I got a bug in a pass oh come get it
from me anymore Wow oh and also you can
complete quests throughout the game so
you get quests you can refill them if
you got the bucks I do so refill them I
don't want music videos I can watch ya
know boy yeah that's the thing about
this game it's legitimately fun because
of how well-made it is and like you get
to see like your comparison rankings
among your friends you get to see like
the comparison rankings between all the
people in rebel mode here and then
there's my channel
and then my real channel up at the top
there but someday I'll get up to your
markiplier and that's why I shaved my
beard because this is me down to number
12 looking up at number 2 up there oh
man someday someday big buddy someday
I'll be up there for you anyway I think
I've showed you pretty much everything
in the game so I'll leave it at that so
thank you everybody so much for watching
and thank you everybody so much for
putting up with the horrifying visits
that you see in front of you but worry
not it is true I never aged but also
you'll never even suspect that this is
actually a clone that escaped from the
cloned basement and soon enough the
authorities will be taking him back down
there and mashing them up into pulp to
make even more clones you guys wouldn't
even imagine that
no I'm timeless but anyway this is
babyface markiplier from 2012 signing
off thank you everybody so much for
watching
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye
[Music]